[Music]
as concert venues and sports teams fight
to bounce back from the pandemic
minor league baseball is in a league of
its own
games were canceled last year and this
season started with restrictions on how
many people can sit in the stands
despite that teams are striking out when
it comes to getting help
and some are on the verge of bankruptcy
as chris van cleave shows us
help may be on the way from the u.s
senate he joins us from prince george's
stadium
in maryland home of the bowie bay sox
chris good morning
good morning from home plate you know in
a typical year more than 40 million fans
come to minor league ballparks but last
year
stadiums across the country looked like
this they were empty now
take the base hawks yes they are
affiliated with a major league club
but 95 percent of the team's revenue
comes from things like ticket sales
concessions and merchandise
things that require fans to be in the
stands
the next pitch is lined into left field
the rocket city trash pandas are hotter
than the madison alabama summer
we love sitting on the grass and the
kids run around and play
they can catch a ball possibly the trash
pandas should have been a 2020 sensation
but then the pandemic happened what does
losing your inaugural season
cost a franchise millions of dollars
probably close to 15
17 million dollars the 2020 season was
canceled just weeks before the first
pitch
and this season saw the first 20 games
axed
leaving the trash pandas trying to save
the club from the financial dumpster
before ever taking the field it was
either
shut the doors and close down and lay
people off or
come up with other creative ways to
bring people here to the ballpark use
the facility and do non-baseball events
and really push our merchandise
they sold 2.5 million worth of trash
panda gear and hosted events like
outdoor summer camp
socially distance movie nights and drive
through christmas lights it was enough
to keep their 30 person staff employed
and the lights on but here in
chattanooga the lookouts didn't have
that kind of flexibility in fact they
went more than 600 days without fans
in these stands since 1885 the lookouts
have been playing professional baseball
one of the oldest teams in the minor
leagues they've weathered the spanish
flu
the great depression and two world wars
but the 2020 season
was nearly the lookout's last are you
still in survival mode in a lot of ways
yes
we dug a huge hole in 2020 and with 21
i'd like to think that we were going to
fill it back in but the truth is
even this year we're still digging just
a little bit slower when play finally
resumed many teams started the shortened
season with capacity limits
2020 season tickets and advertising
sales were rolled over to this year
but by then teams had used that money to
stay afloat
as a result 2021 revenue is expected to
be down
65 percent from 2019. they are on the
brink of
financial catastrophe help for the
nation's past
time could be coming from an unlikely
team political
polar opposites democratic senator
richard blumenthal and republican
marsha blackburn how often do you two
find yourself on the same side of an
issue i would say we
vote together probably rarely
but on baseball they agree the two are
co-sponsoring legislation to use 550
million in unspent covet relief funds
to help eligible minor league teams that
were shut out of earlier grants for live
event venues
these are days they don't get back they
are drivers for jobs for tourism
this is very much a part of your
local economic system in these
communities
the 120 minor league teams pay about 50
million in local taxes annually and
raise another 50 million for local
charities
prior to the pandemic they employed
nearly 35 000
full and part-time employees even as
fans
filled into superhero night at atnt
field
the chattanooga lookout's future is on
the mind of ticket scanner dan mummert
there'd be a lot of us that would be
without jobs
and i think that's important to the
community is for to
employ people of the community and
that's what the lookouts do
what would it mean for chattanooga if
the lookouts don't survive yeah it's
unthinkable frankly
tim kelly is chattanooga's newly elected
mayor when most people think of sports
they're thinking of major league teams
owned by billionaires
and this is not that it's critically
important to towns like irish that
minor league sports survive and thrive
now without help the lookouts owner told
us assuming
nothing else goes wrong the delta
variant doesn't become more of an issue
it will take
his team up to a decade to recover from
the financial losses
and i want to leave you with this on
average a family of four can go to a
minor league baseball game
tickets and a meal for under 70 dollars
tickets here
start at eight bucks which may leave you
enough money to get a hat
for you and your favorite anchor team
that's great yeah we got our hats
mine are the trash pandas thanks for
looking out chris we got our hats
i was going to say that exact same thing
now to say thank you chris
but aside from the economics chris it
just shows what it does
sports and music always very very
healing for people you can they can
social distance it's outside
and you don't think about minor league
baseball the way that you just showed it
showed it it makes a lot of sense well
in a lot of these communities it's a
real flagship yeah
it's a built point of pride and 70
that's cheaper than a movie
you can't get a mix ticket for 70 bucks
i don't think exactly
well chris thank you again we really
appreciate it